oh my goodness how is this  possible today it's gonna be david  versus goliath what about amd's best  mobile processors and nvidia's best  mobile graphics card and unlocked rtx  3080 we have this huge 17 inch main gear  vector pro compared to a tiny slim 14  inch macbook pro on battery there's a  dedicated button on there for the best  performance so there you go we're in  turbo and now let's get into graphics  and just to show you guys i do have the  3080 unlocked and i'm gonna run gfx  bench which is both optimized for cuda  and metal and our main gear laptops fans  are blazing sorry 32 core m1 max  the rtx has it now let's go ahead and  see how these graphics can perform when  we unplug it david is winning which i  guess in the story it makes sense david  wins